John's mojo is re teaching us the
language of symbolism and showing us
just how life-giving the level is if we
have yours to see if you have ears to
hear if we have eyes to see everyone
that possibilies knows just how excited
I've been to have Jonathan come so I'm
really dirty am I supposed to have such
high expectations but please do listen
to this man as he's welcomed him today
[Applause]
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so I want to thank you Kelly thank you
for inviting me and the Bossip fellows
as well and thank you Father for having
us here it's really wonderful to be in
Boston and to see a bunch of a lot of
people and a kind of this it's kind of
the the crowd is without what I was
expecting
you know Hannah 20s early 30s that's my
image of Boston I guess and I yesterday
I was walking around Boston and I was
pretty confirmed in my image there's all
these young people walking around and so
what I want to talk to you about today
is I want to give you a story of art
it's going to be a story of art that's
going to be maybe a little different
from the one you're used to hearing I
want to try to trace the story of art in
Scripture and how it relates to our life
today or what it means for us today and
when I'm going to talk about the story
of art it's actually going to end up
being more than just art in the very
narrow way that we understand art today
it's going to end up being the story of
art as the entirety of human making the
entirety of human activity what how can
we trace this line in Scripture and how
does it relate to us today in the church
and also as we see Christianity erode in
our culture what does that also mean for
human making what does that look like in
terms of human making
in the Orthodox tradition for those of
you are Orthodox there's an interesting
little issue there is a kind of duality
in terms of human making or in terms of
let's say liturgical art or beautiful
things beautiful architecture is that on
the one hand we have an ascetic
tradition and in this ascetic tradition
here we have an image of st. simeon the
skylight who stood on a pillar for most
of his life and just stood there for day
and night you know living this extreme
ascetic life and the image of the Desert
Fathers and the image of the life of the
monk and the ascetic is the lifeblood of
the Orthodox tradition it is it is what
ensues 'as we the saints that we
venerate the stories that we tell of the
early Desert Fathers that is the the
lifeblood and the mystical tradition of
the church as well the hesychast ik
tradition has these very extreme
pronouncements about human activity
about images about image making which is
that the purpose of the mystic is to
attain pure prayer without any images
without any language without any
exteriority whatsoever but to enter into
the divine darkness and experience
oneness with God without any form at all
so how do we connect that to something
like this how does that match how can we
have a tradition that also celebrates
this this this plethora of image making
that we have this exuberance in terms of
our art terms of ornamentation gold all
of this when we go up into the church
later you'll see you know it's it's gold
mosaic and there is a you know carved
marble and all of this kind of
exuberance how do we connect those two
together and we see tension even in the
the Christian Church even in the
Orthodox tradition will
the tension appear once in a while in
that issue you'll find a very sober
priest will quote to you you know a
homily of st. John Chrysostom which says
that we shouldn't which would be careful
we shouldn't have gold we should use
gold for make churches we should help
the poor and so you have this idea you
know we have to help the poor we have to
be ascetic we have to be this and then
you also have the other side where we
have Hagia Sophia which became the model
for all the churches in the world and
all the mosques in the world actually
and became the cornerstone of
architecture for the West for centuries
right so we have this these two things
so what I want to do is I want to go
into the the story and look at why these
two types of these two traditions how do
they come together in Christianity one
of my main the main people that go to is
st. Gregory of Nisa because he is his
understanding of Christian symbolism is
is uh no one beats him in his
understanding if you read the life of of
Moses you get a very powerful vision of
the Old Testament and this vision of the
the mystical union with God in the Old
Testament and but if you read st.
Gregory Mesa it seems like he's really
on the side of the let's say on the side
of the ascetic um let me just read you a
quote from st. Gregory in his text on
virginity so so st. Gregory says that we
need to renounce marriage right we need
to renounce all these things and
renounce toil the the work that was
given to Adam we need to really renounce
even to reject the deception that is
given to us
even through taste and sight itself and
he talks about to be with God alone and
enjoy this delight continuously and
without interruption and no longer to
mingle with with this repose nothing
which draws us in the opposite direction
and so we talked about being snatched up
into the divine presence and Saint
Gregory uses this story of Moses
ascending the mountain if you look at
the story of Moses ascending the
mountain that's exactly the structure
that that that is given by saint gregory
of nyssa as Moses ascends the mountain
he is returning to paradise the mountain
of Sinai is also the mountain of
paradise if you look at if you look at
this image you can see Moses atop and
you see this glory of God I don't know
if you can see this little glory of God
at the top of the mountain
so he's going up and he's entering into
the divine presence and to do that he
has to get rid of all the external
coverings he has to remove his sandals
he has to also shed the people that were
with him there's this image in the open
in the Old Testament in Exodus where as
Moses goes up the mountain at first he
leaves all the people below and then as
he's going up he's going up with all the
elders he leaves the elders and then he
goes up with Aaron with with with Joshua
then he leaves Joshua then he finds
himself alone at the top of the mountain
and so this is really the image of the
shedding of all the externals and moving
into the oneness of God and in that you
really do find this image of of
hesychasm this image of the mystical
vision of Orthodoxy which is this pure
oneness with God and you can see the
image of the mountain is exactly that
right because you move from many things
you move from a large base and as you go
up and get smaller and smaller and that
you reach the top then you know you can
imagine it imagine almost like a pyramid
at the very top there's room for only
one point there's just one point at the
top and that's the oneness and when
you're up there then you look at the
world and you can see the entire you
have this this over
you of everything because you've reached
the top and you have joined with heaven
so the very image is is that so then we
can also understand the opposite as
being related to this fall from oneness
into the many and that is what we see in
the story of the Garden of Eden the
story of Moses is this going up into the
oneness of God into the into the to the
top where heaven meets earth and the
fall of the garden is the opposite it's
this moving away from the oneness up at
the top of a mountain and then moving
out into the many into the the all the
things that are outside the distractions
of the outside the so the imagery that's
used in in Scripture is that and that's
also the image that saint gregory of
nyssa uses as well so imagine now Adam
and Eve are in the garden at first Adam
is not even separated into two he's 1
and this is actually an important thing
that we see in the church fathers the
tradition in the church fathers which is
that even the the separation of Adam
into two people to make this androgynous
being into two was already looking
forward to the fall so the separation
into into male and female then finally
Adam and Eve are seduced by the serpent
and they have to leave the garden and
leaving the garden is this going down
into the world when they were in the
garden they were naked and we need to
understand this nakedness in the context
of this image of the mountain keep this
image of the one and the many you know
just keep that image in your minds I'm
going to keep coming back to it all the
time in the garden they were naked they
didn't need
anything from the outside they had
everything they needed within that
communion with God they didn't need to
add something from the outside to build
something from the outside they just had
all they needed was the communion and as
soon as they fall then this nakedness
the Church Fathers talked about how his
nakedness was actually they were clothed
in glory it wasn't that it was naked the
way we think of it but it was rather
that that they didn't need external
thing they were emanating they were you
know they were emanating light you can
imagine it that way
they were emanating glory they didn't
need to cover themselves as soon as they
fall then they have to they they become
ashamed right they look up you know they
they understand that God is there and
all of a sudden they feel like they have
to hide themselves from God so what do
they do they take leaves and they try to
cover themselves that is the very first
human act act in the sense of the first
human making the first things the human
made was clothing first human art let's
talk about it that way so you'll see
where I'm going right away the first
human art is clothing and what's its
purpose its to cover it's to protect its
to hide okay and so you can also
understand it as you're moving down from
the mountain so imagine now again the
Sun above above the world the sun is
shining down right and at some point the
Sun becomes a threat to you just like
for them God actually became to them in
their perception God became a threat to
them and so they wanted to cover
themselves they wanted some shade from
this from something that was above them
and that is what art is
and that is why art in the Old Testament
is actually pretty negative has a very
negative connotation and I'm going to
show you I'm going to bring you through
it but you're gonna see that actually
human activity human making is actually
a very negative aspect and it's not just
even in the Bible but even let's say in
Hellenistic culture it was the same idea
they had this notion that true knowledge
was at Eastham a true knowledge was the
knowledge of the principles are the
knowledge of the higher things and and
Tecna craft or art it wasn't you know
it's like applied knowledge and there's
something about that that's almost like
degrading of knowledge down into the
world you know think of Plato and his
idea of the shadows of the of the pure
forms and then the shadows in the world
and so it's not just it we don't only
see it in the Bible we see it in other
cultures as well where this idea that
the higher things when you when you make
when you cover yourself
you're hiding yourself from the higher
things it becomes a veil it becomes a
separation all right so now using the
word veil is probably a very good word
for you to understand what it's
referring to the veils in the temple the
veils of the tabernacle it was all about
that it was all about hiding you know
protecting ourselves from the glory of
God but also protecting the glory of God
from being desecrated from the outside
okay so that's the clothing
and then as they fall God gives them
garments of skin and the garments of
skin are the best image to understand
this clothing to understand this
addition to our nature this adding that
we put on top because the garments of
skin are made of dead animals they're
made of death it's using death to
protect us from death taking something
dead making it as a covering so that you
protect yourself from death outside so
why did they wear the garments of skin
what were they protecting themselves
from in the scripture from the thorns
God says you go down the mountain you
come down and then you encounter the
hostility of the world you know being
naked up in in a garden in the glory of
God it's all fine but being naked out in
the woods it's not fine because you get
you get a step on thorns you you know
you and that's why they wear these
garments st. Gregory sangra Missa is
amazing because he he says that Moses
his sandals are the garments of skin
it's a perfect image but because these
skins sandals on the bottom of your feet
to protect yourselves from the thorns
and the spikes and the hostility of the
ground is a very beautiful image to help
you understand to understand this now
what's what's important is that we need
to understand this covering now not just
as clothing you know clothing is the
image it really ends up being everything
that humans do in the world of the fall
basically our whole state of death our
whole state of living death you could
say you know of fighting death of being
in a world of death of constantly having
to deal with the reality of the
hostility of the outside so if you want
to read a more about this this beauty
idea of the garments of skin there's a
wonderful classic orthodox book called
deification in christ by by panayotis
nellis I'm going to quote something from
his where he talked about st. John
Chrysostom and nellis says st. John
Chrysostom teaches that before the fall
man had no need either for cities or for
arts and skills or for the covering of
clothing these were then super
superfluous he continues but afterwards
they became necessary because of our
infirmity and not only these things but
everything else the whole throng of
remaining necessities and death entered
with all these dragging all of them in
along with itself so there's a play
between death and these protections from
death there's a game happening between
the two right as you go further out into
the world you need to build stronger and
stronger things and the classic example
is let say I'm from Montreal you know
when my you know when my ancestors maybe
a very long time ago lived in warmer
climates you didn't need much but now if
I go outside without a winter coat and
and boots I'm gonna die so to live
further out in the world of death we
need more and more covering more and
more civilization more and more
structures an army weapons a wall around
the city etc etc like we need buildings
to protect ourselves from the elements
to protect ourselves from attacks to
protect ourselves from the people
viewing you know spying on us or
whatever it is that we do that's why we
need we need buildings right and now in
the story of Scripture and now oh and
medicine is the same by the way and
medicine is exactly the same structure
it it's a human activity which uses
death to put death away because all
medicine is poison at all the medicine
it's all poison it's all something that
can kill you we use something that can
kill you
in order to stop something that's
killing you so we play this game and we
have to be careful it's a fine line
between you know you you you have cancer
you go take chemotherapy and the
chemotherapy is killing you when you're
trying to heal your cancer so it's like
this this line that you're always
playing you you take a vaccine you get
injected with a disease in order to
fight off a disease right this is the
this is the process of the garments of
skin
now in order to accentuate that this is
really what you see in Scripture you
have to read the genealogies in the
Bible no one likes to read the
genealogies but there's great stuff in
the genealogies of the Bible every
single human activity in scripture that
the basic human activities are developed
by the children of Cain Cain who killed
his brother Cain who was chased out so
think of it think of the garden again as
this mountain sin Ephraim the Syrian he
talks about the Garden of Eden as the
entire cosmos he says that the Garden of
Eden is a mountain whose summit reaches
above all summits and whose base reaches
across the ocean so he talks about this
image this structure this mountain is
basically being the entire cosmos is
this mountain so Adam and Eve fall they
get they go down they're chased down the
mountain as they go down the mountain
they're further from the oneness of the
top they're going towards more many more
quantity as they're moving away from
from the top and then Cain kills his
brother and he gets chased further down
the mountain so the the children of Seth
are above the higher up on the mountain
and the children of Cain are lower down
in the mountains they're closer to the
hostility in Scripture it says that he's
chased out into the Land of Nod into
this land that he's like you know like a
wilderness and so because of that Kane
himself founds the first city
anybody else knows anybody who know
another story of someone who founded a
city after you killed his brother Rome
yes remember that remember that okay
Rome is also founded by someone who
tried to kill his brother okay and as as
Kane goes down the mountain as his
descendants go down the mountain we have
this idea that the children of Cain
become the ultimate outsider the
ultimate foreigner you would say the
ultimate thing that you don't know what
it is and this is this is a tradition
that spans in very strange ways all
across storytelling you even find it in
the story of Beowulf where in the story
of Beowulf Grendel and his mother are
actually descendants of Cain these these
like primordial monsters that live in
the swamp and in the forest are actually
these descendants of Cain but you can
imagine it like this you command unit
that the on the top of the mountain we
are these these humans in the image of
God and as we get further and further
down the mountain we resemble God less
we resemble the animals more we wear
animal skins on us and as we go down
then we start to become monstrous as we
get further and further out but it's not
just Cain and founded the city his
descendants also did other things and
then in his line you have these Lamech
has these different kids one is named
jebel who is the father of those who
dwell in tents his brother's name is
Jubal and he was the one who created the
musical instruments and then finally one
of his children is tubal Cain and tubal
Cain
is the instructor of every craftsman in
bronze and iron so we have Kane founds
the first city so he found sedentary
lifestyle Cain's children are the first
nomads who live in tents and carry
livestock his children are the first
artists they are the first musicians
they create musical instruments and his
children are the first artists they are
the first craftsmen they are the ones
who make make med-alert use metallurgy
to make things and so you can see that
all civilizations it comes from the bad
side it comes from the dark side you
could say and I'm sorry everybody's like
all this girls don't worry there's a
happy ending okay everything's gonna be
okay but for now we need to understand
this first if we want to understand the
salvation that Christ brings you have to
understand the dark part first and in in
the in the tradition other traditions
that say extra-biblical tradition it
goes even further than what I'm telling
you here in the extra-biblical
traditions for example nutritions around
the Book of Enoch it's the demons who
teach human beings their skills so it's
not just that Cain develops these the
skills but it's actually fallen angels
who are teaching the skills and think
about it in terms of think about in
terms of what I've been telling you like
we get all hung up about the images of
fallen angels and all this but think
about this the image I had about the
mountain of coming down the mountain
how applied knowledge is moving is
coming taking something above and
bringing it below okay and so it's not
that strange to imagine that these
angels these principalities these higher
beings are falling and they're the ones
who are teaching the skills to human
beings like whether you think it's a
legitimate tradition or not
just try to understand it it can help
you understand the story and why in the
time of Christ these these traditions
were very very prominent so in the book
of Enoch it talks about different demons
one major demon and is as Iselle and it
says that as Iselle taught men to make
swords and knives and shields and
breastplates and Maino to them the
metals of the earth and the art of
working them now think of the the metal
part is really important very important
because metal is digging in the ground
remember the mountain remember this this
pyramid right metallurgy is digging in
the ground taking stuff from underground
bringing it up and then using that right
it's a very dark thing and all the all
the imagery around metallurgy and every
culture is very dark you know you have
the image of hephaistos this this
deformed God in Greek and Roman myth
that lives in Hades you know that lives
in this dark firey place and is pounding
and making and just the even think of a
blacksmith and any you know in any kind
of fantastic story that you get living
in this soot and banging on metal and
taking this ore out of the ground you
know it's a very dark imagery so how
does though teaches people to make
weapons but he doesn't only teach them
to make weapons he also teaches them to
make bracelets and ornaments and to use
antimony now antimony is very strained
but the reason it seems to me why he
says to use antimony is because in the
ancient times antimony was a metal that
was used to decorate the eyelids so he's
connecting metallurgy and weapon making
with ornaments with decorating
and and so he says they use antimony and
the beautifying of the eyelids and all
kinds of costly stones and all coloring
and tinctures and there arose much
godlessness and they committed
fornication they were led astray and
became corrupt in all their ways so why
is ornamentation connected with this
making something beautiful why wouldn't
we want to make something beautiful you
know now ornamentation is the ultimate
garment of skin does the ultimate thing
that you add you can think about it this
way and I tried to explain it think of
someone why would someone need to wear
makeup sorry it's all the ladies like
why do you wear makeup right do you wear
makeup in order to enhance your beauty
okay all right so you and so you you you
put something you add something in order
to enhance your beauty now if you push
that a little further right and you you
say you put on more makeup you put on
more makeup when is where's the line
between enhancing your beauty and hiding
what's there okay that's the line right
that's the line that I'm talking about
if this this idea of adding something in
order to enhance but then you're also
hiding your your kammath you know your
camouflage Inge what is there your your
supplementing in order to hide as well
okay that's the that's the line that is
going on in this in this whole game and
that's why the ornamentation that the
demons teach ornamentation is related to
making cities and making walls and
weapons
because why do we we use why do we need
why would you want a sword you want a
sword to enhance your strength right
that's the same thing too every
technology has the same function every
single technology has the same function
it's to enhance something but it also
can be a way to hide that which is
lacking the example I like to use is
always a book of matches I can my
ancestors had a lot of pain to start
fires like they suffered to start fires
I don't suffer just take out my book of
matches there you go I've got fire well
what do I do if I don't have that book
of matches can I start a fire I don't
know how to start a fire all right my
ancestors knew how to start a fire if
they didn't have a book of matches they
can still start a fire it's the same for
everything around us right we have cars
you can go very far and now our whole
society shifts and now if you don't have
a car what do you do if you live in the
suburbs can't believe without a car
because you actually the grocery store
is too far away from your house you
would actually die of hunger if you
didn't have a car okay um trying to help
you to think that way in order to help
you understand the problem of the
problem of supplementarity and the
problem of of craft
and so there is a there's a relationship
between death and glory those two are
very connected because that's what an
ornament is that as well right.we
ornament something to help you see its
glory why would you ornament something
usually is because you want people to
think it's special right you have a
plane chair you have this special chair
if you have the chair you used to eat
and then you have the chair for the king
and the chair for the king has got to be
fancier than the chair that you just sit
in for dinner
right so you ornament the chair of the
king in order for you to know that it is
special to reveal the glory right to
manifest the glory but that the game is
still there because you can also fake it
right okay all right so hopefully I've
got you thinking in the right direction
so sadly art is related to the fall it
is related to this problem of the world
of death and every all human activity in
this world of death is a problem but now
we come to this moment where God starts
to reveal himself to the people in
Scripture and we start to see what God
does with the fall this is where the
good part of the story starts to appear
we see how God is constantly changing if
we in the fall changed our glory into
death God is constantly taking that
death and changing it back into glory
and this is the story of salvation this
is the story of salvation all the way to
Christ all the way to the end of the
obscure in Revelations and so I told you
that in the story of Moses to ascend the
mountain and really
in the version that st. Gregor Mesa
gives you is the is the best version
because he really captures this ascetic
movement this removing now in order to
enter into the presence of God he has to
remove all the veils the veils of the
heart he talks about we have to remove
them even he has to remove his sandals
he has to remove all these people and he
moves up and up and up into the unity
into the one oneness of God and there he
has shed all of this exteriority all of
the outside and said Gregor of Mesa uses
crazy imagery to help you understand
what he's referring to he talks about he
talks about the the idea of the Egyptian
for example the Egyptian as this foreign
power which is not connected to the god
of Revelation and so the Egyptians who
died in the flood are being shed away
shedding away this foreign thing and the
the foreign thing is also the the
shedding of the foreigners also
circumcision the shedding of this extra
skin right shedding the extra skin
shedding the foreigner all of this
imagery and then moving up the mountain
entering into the divine darkness and
it's amazing but then so you think
that's it right everything we do is
useless and everything we do is
pointless all of this human activity
it's all pointless it's all nothing it's
all and to a certain extent that's true
we always have to remember that to a
certain extent that's true but then
something happens up when Moses reaches
up there in the divine darkness
something happens which flips it what
does God give Moses gives them two
things really he gives him the law he
also gives him something else what does
he give him anybody can guess he gives
them the plan for the tabernacle okay
and say okay says he gives them the
archetype of the tabernacle and he says
that the archetype of the tabernacle is
Christ himself he gives he gives Moses a
vision of Christ in this plan of the
tabernacle and in the tabernacle so
here's the tent of the tabernacle so in
the tabernacle what do we have we have
the same structure that I gave you he's
giving him a little version of the whole
structure that I told you about the
tabernacle has different courts in the
outer court outside of the tabernacle
the foreigners can be there only
Israelites are allowed to enter into the
the actual inner court of the tabernacle
and then and then from that only the
priestly Casa is allowed to enter into
the into the the holy place there's a
veil and a veil and then in the inner
inner inner part only one person the
high priest is allowed to enter once a
year in the very high place in order to
come into the presence and the glory of
God so tabernacle is a mountain
it's a mountain it's the mountain in the
sense that there's many on the outside
and there's fewer and fewer and fewer
and there are these levels these veils
and when you go into the Holy of Holies
you're going back into the Garden of
Eden - there's a reason why there are
they're on the outside of the Garden of
Eden there's a cherub which protects the
garden and why there's a cherub on the
veil of the temple because entering into
the temple is also entering into the
garden and it's also going up the
mountain all these things are all the
same image okay but what's fascinating
is that God is giving Moses this pattern
this whole pattern he's telling him this
is how
you make the Vails this is how you make
the courts and even on the outside of
the tent there are these animal skins
which are dyed red so the garment that
the tabernacle has garments of skins
understand that the same garments of
skin that Adam had when he left the
garden so this is the wildest this is
the craziest thing Moses spent all this
time stripping away all these externals
and then when he gets into the presence
of God what does God give him he gives
them all back to him the whole thing
even the garments of skin he gives him
back and in st. Gregor Nisa you read you
read you can read in st. Gregory Nice's
words when he's talking about this
almost this scandal like he asked him he
has to tell us don't be don't worry when
you see the garments of skin in the
tabernacle like don't worry about it
don't go get freaked out because you
think that you wouldn't see that this
dead thing in the pattern of the
tabernacle but he says don't worry and
then he says that it's the sacrifice of
Christ we'll get to that a bit later
and what's interesting is that God tells
Moses that he he tells him who's going
to build the tabernacle he names them he
gives he gives Moses the name of the
people that are going to build the
tabernacle and the two names are bezalel
and oholiab the name Bezalel means the
shadow of God and the name oholiab means
father's tent okay you see that those
two things are the same they're the same
image the shadow the tent the covering
and so the names of the people that are
building the tabernacle are related to
this very pattern they had in their name
that and one of them oh holy odd is in
says that he's from the tribe of Dan
which is if you know what the tribe of
Dan is you'll understand how a wild that
is because the prophecy about the tribe
of Dan
when Jacob prophesizes on his sons is he
says let Dan be a serpent by the
roadside a horned Viper by the path that
bites the horses heel so that the rider
tumbles backwards so Dan is related to
the fall itself he's the serpent he is
that which makes you fall oholiab is his
descendants is also very strange he is a
descendant of calleb callebaut means dog
and calleb is ambiguously also a
foreigner he seems like he's a kena
sight and he takes the margin of the of
the country so there's this whole thing
going on where God is actually taking
the very imagery of the fall itself he's
taking the very imagery of these animals
on the periphery
and he's flipping it he's saying okay
I'm gonna use this and I'm actually
going to turn it into glory and that's
where you see the beginning of the
incarnation Allah principle the one
which will culminate in Christ we
already see it what do we say that
Christ did when he descended into Hades
when Christ was on the cross we say he
trampled death by death that it is his
death which trampled death and by doing
that Christ's death is his glory thank
you when you see Christ on the cross you
were seeing the highest thing when you
see Christ on the cross you are seeing
the most glorious thing that you've ever
seen and that is this flip that happens
this incarnation 'el principle and it
goes on you'll see like it goes on
because you know I I really try to show
you how the the craft is related also to
something that is outside something that
you need to add from the outside in
order to protect yourself right and so
it's that's why it's also related to
this idea of something which is foreign
like the foreigner is related to craft
making can you kind of see how that
makes sense which is why a holy act
which is why Bezalel is from is from a
Kennedy descendants from this kind of
foreign group because you have to kind
of take that which is from the outside
in order to make the wall you know
that's always what you're doing when
you're when you're protecting yourself
from the outside you're gathering
something in and you're making a wall
out of it in order to protect yourself
from the outside you see that the story
of humanity is there are so many
examples of that where you hire a
barbarian tribe to fight off the
barbarians the Romans do it all the time
you you you you take something from the
outside and you turn it against the
that's what that's what's medicine is
all of that is the same and that's also
what ornamentation is if you look at
ornaments they are very spiky they're
they're made out of foliage they're made
out of labyrinths they're made out of
all this imagery of knots of all of this
is related to this this idea of taking
something bringing it together and
holding out the outside you know when
you know you everybody has this idea we
talk about how ornaments used to be
protection they use their magical they
people would put ornaments on things in
order to to protect themselves right you
put ornaments on buildings people kind
of joke about it you know you put a
Greek key on the building to stop the
evil spirits from coming in you know you
put in you put a labyrinth outside to
stop the evil influences from coming in
and we think ha ha ha it's all
superstitious all silly it's all
nonsense but when did you start to
understand this this process you can
understand that that's what we do all
the time right that if you don't like
the ritual version of it right if you
don't like that then you have to
understand that when you make an army or
if you hire mercenaries from the outside
or if you if you do all this kind of
things then you're actually
participating in the same pattern even
if you're not doing it ritually you know
the ancients just did things ritually as
well in order to manifest the pattern in
in in a very proper way
all right so as this story keeps going
in Scripture the same pattern just
repeats itself over and over and over
and over that's what that's what
Scripture is like I want to beat you
over the head with this pattern so that
you can see it because people don't seem
to see it so when they now from the
tabernacle they build the temple
King David gets the plan of the temple
but this King David build the temple who
builds a temple Solomon but not really
Solomon Solomon manages it kind of but
he's not the one who actually builds it
you know who built it the Phoenicians
build it the king of Tyre its foreigners
foreigners build the temple okay it's
the same story over and over and if you
read that text where it talks about
Solomon building the temple it's very
fascinating because the biblical authors
are just so amazing they there's this
strange relationship between Solomon
building the temple but him also being
visited by the Queen of Sheba and so in
the same text talks about how Solomon is
associating himself with the king of
Tyre in order to build the temple but
then he's also being visited by this
Queen this ultimate foreigner in a way
you know the Queen the Ethiopian Queen
who comes from the ends of the earth
who's coming to now to to to interact
with Solomon and so these two things are
actually related together and then in
the king and the story of Solomon you
actually see the downside of that
because he goes too far if you go too
far and that what you end up happening
the end of having foreign gods right if
you go too far out and you're not
careful of that line then you pick up
things from the outside which are not or
not don't connect you then you end up
having these serving these foreign gods
and that will make you fall
and you have to think about it think
about it already now in terms of our own
Christian tradition it's always been
this tension as Christianity develops
its forms it was taking things from the
cultures that it lands in taking things
from Roman culture taking things from
Greek culture taking things from
Ethiopian from Armenian from Georgian
from all these cultures its gathering
these things in and then it's it's
developing its craft its art its beauty
its ornaments all based on these foreign
things that they're bringing in and
there's always this line this tension
sometimes maybe they go little bit too
far sometimes they you know they so it's
like you can see a play that's happening
all right now then we come to Christ
Christ has everything every strain in
the Bible culminates into him every
symbolic strain that you find from
Genesis it all culminates into Christ
and so does this one Christ is called
what
Hey Crysis Crysis is called the
carpenter and it's interesting because
in the scripture you actually see in the
moment where Christ is being called the
carpenter you see this pattern that I'm
telling you about
because when the Pharisees say that
Christ is a carpenter are they doing it
to his glory no they're doing it to
demean him they're doing it to mock him
they're saying isn't he that carpenter
right because being a carpenter is a
very low thing compared to what Christ
is supposed to be you know in the idea
that he would be the Messiah who or he
would be the chosen one that would be
the anointed that he would be the the
the prophet that he would be all these
high things like oh no he's just a
craftsman of course the Pharisees did
not understand what Christ was going to
do which is that he was going to enter
into all the dark places that he was
going to go down into death that he was
going to fill death with light that he
was going to fill death with glory and
that is one of the things that Christ is
doing by being called a carpenter even
if it is in a mocking manner he is
filling that aspect of the world with
divinity he is his infusing it he's
transforming it and the transformation
was already happening before we can see
it in the in the tabernacle can see it
in the temple you can see it in all
these moments where God uses these
externals all these garments all these
additions all these human acts and flips
them changes them turns them into glory
now the story doesn't stop there right
the same thing happens with Christianity
the same thing happens with Christianity
even more so even more so than what's in
the Old Testament did is it is it is it
the Jews that developed the arts of the
Christian Church no that's not who is it
it's the Romans the Romans who developed
the Christian arts and and a lot of
people they say that to criticize it
they say that to mock the Christian
tradition as if this was a scandalous
moment in our church where all the
sudden Christianity took on these Roman
forms but no no no this is the story
this is the story we have to understand
that Christ is one other thing Christ
it's not all these doing Christ is doing
everything but one of the things Christ
is doing is saving cane he's redeeming
came he is the first born you ever
noticed that in Scripture it's always
the second born after cane canes the
first born and then everybody else who's
important in Scripture is always the
second or the last right and then Christ
appears and Christ is the firstborn and
not only is he the firstborn but he is
he is he converts the Romans he converts
the ones who killed him he converts the
the ones who killed their brother and
founded the city so the story of the
conversion of Rome is is in
one of the most important aspects of
understanding what Christianity is what
Christ is doing and so what's important
when we think of art we have to keep in
mind the two images of Christ
there are many images of Christ but
basically really there's really two
images of Christ the two basic images of
Christ is Christ in glory and Christ
crucified Christ dressed as a Roman
Emperor a Roman senator holding a book
making a Roman gesture of a dress and
Christ on the cross being killed by the
Romans those two images solved the
problem they solve the problem as you go
up into paradise as you move as Moses
goes up into the top of the mountain as
Christ entered into the Holy of Holies
when the veil was ripped while he was on
the cross he was entering into the
garden right as that happened he was
also going down into the bottom of the
mountain all the way to the edge of the
world all the way to the edge of death
he was doing both at the same time while
he was being crucified he was spanning
the entire cosmos
all right that's why when we have Christ
with his hands stretched out and we have
the Sun and the moon on the side Christ
filled the world when he died on the
cross was doing both and so when you and
so we have now as Christians we have
those
traditions and they're fine together we
have an aesthetic tradition of those who
go up the mountain and remove the
garments and these monks who live in
caves and have nothing and eat almost
nothing and pray without ceasing we have
that tradition and we have the glory of
a church covered in gold mosaic and
resplendent filling the world of the
world with this light and using
ornamentation you know if you look at
Hagia Sophia a friend of mine pointed
out that all the ornamentation in Hagia
Sophia is Persian
it's not even Rome it's going further
it's taking Persian ornamentation and
bringing it into the Roman the Roman
Church and manifesting through its
ornamentation the radiation the rate the
radiance of the kingdom of God and the
final image of that the ultimate image
of that is in Revelations how does the
world end does the world end in a garden
the final image is not a garden the
final image is a city right New
Jerusalem that's the final image the
garden is in the middle the Tree of Life
in the middle you know the water of life
in the middle and around it this
glorious city of gold and jewels and
that's the ultimate image everything has
been filled all of human activity has
been sanctified has been glorified has
been changed into glory that's the final
image so that is the first part of my
talk I wanted to give you kind of a
story of art help you understand the
problem and how Christ and the creep and
the Christian Church bring a solution to
that problem and so this afternoon I'm
then I'm gonna try to talk about how we
can do that in terms of artists there
are people making things in the world
and how to deal with that so this is
going to be the end of my first part
with what time is it 11:15 and so I have
some questions that they would like to
ask yesterday we're glad you're here
because I always wanted to ask you this
question it seems that you're giving
them a negative stance to creativity and
art it all makes sense sort of scheme
are they
however it seems to me that part of
being in the image and likeness of God
is creativity because the greatest
artist is God and God obviously he
creates and he has no Givens to limit
him but we have Givens because were
created and therefore we kind of like
bump into these Givens that's kind of
like the annoyance of an artist like
Michelangelo this is a block of marble
he says you know I wish I could get rid
of this marble and you can see the pure
program there it seems to me that that
which makes the human made in the
Internet
and the fact that pain always wants to
vomit and sand the Gibbons because this
give a seed of this total freedom of God
who has no Givens therefore we have this
Gibbons and what we do is if you have a
dog let's say you bring them in this
beautiful Paul after three months look
at worst if we put a human being here
vacuum on people but his or her personal
stamp onto this room with art and so on
so but it seems to me that part of being
human is his art and yet you seem to be
connected with the four now even before
the fall because you're not talking
about is the scientific way in
symbolically human being was told to be
creative and transformed the Gibbons in
other words the gift that was given he
was not told to just sit there inert
because that's an atom an animal would
do nothing or make it worse
but we put our personal stamp onto
whatever is given us and you say that's
before the fall hmm and it seems to me
that's inherent in what it means to be a
human being
in other words this idea of
transforming putting our personal
statment making cities is another
example of that because it's art and
that seems to me if it's connected with
being human human connectedness
specifically with with the former God
now the human being he's supposed to in
Genesis transform the garden cultivate
it and give it back to God so God and
his turn can give it back to us as
communities basically that's what we do
in our liturgy we don't bring in you
know wheat and grapes but we bring in
bread and wine animals can't do that and
so the human being is not the image in
light of God because we're smart because
animals are smart too but we are
creative there are artists and a God is
the great artists that were made in His
image so that they could come and
connect before let me just say one more
thing to make you happy because stone
hmm
we like to say in what's been Europe you
know carpenter Tecton yes he was
actually a storm they can have wood
Indian next there's no wood you know
they're not gonna waste wood so far yes
he could have been a stone carver Tecton
really means
he was an artisan it's like he could
have been like an art and applied and
applied hey it's a general term to talk
about art of it one of the greatest
types of Christ in the Old Testament is
milk isn't it yeah
and he was there know where he was from
and he was a form yeah yet he was giving
a blessing to Abraham so again it fits
in with this beautiful schema I love the
way you do this and I think it's a great
service there to one of them I thank you
for your podcast and your youtubes yeah
well I think there are a few things
going on here
did anybody have everybody hear the
question yes most yeah okay I'll let me
repeat it so father was mentioning the
difficulty that he sees in what I'm
saying because he says seems like God
creating Adam carrying the human being
in the image and likeness of God that
creation creating would be part of that
and that Adam in the garden was creative
in the sense that he tended the garden
there are other aspects as well and so
he's wondering why is it that I want to
relate it to the fall so much rather
than related to this idea that in
creation itself as God created man then
man is also a creator and so I think I
think father I agree with you I agree
with you I think that you you're kind of
you're kind of eating into my second
talk you know but the way to the way to
understand it but there are some things
that you said that I would probably
wonder about like that would make me
think is that I I'm not sure so for
example Adam names the animals and
that's a great example of him acting
like as a small creator you know and so
God creates the animals and then Adam
names them and naming something is is
part of participating in its existence
you know you you give it you point at it
then you give it a name and so you
actually pull it out of the of the world
and in a similar way that God pulls
creation out of primordial
earth let's say but I think that I think
that when for for that to be true it has
to be us acting in the image of God
which is that the stamp that we put on
the world has to be God shaped that it's
not so much that we're putting our
personal individual stamp and because we
faced with so many so many ideas of
expressing yourself you know everybody
has heard that so many times like that
that we have to express ourselves I
think that that's I think that we need
to express God that's what I think we
need to Express I think that we need to
be the vehicles to manifest God out in
the world and that of course is going to
be beauty that of course is going to be
certain patterns which are true and and
sin so we do participate in God let's
say radiating out into the world through
our actions but that's when that's when
that flip happens that's when we're not
that's when we take something which was
the V do live in the world of the fall
right and so but what ultimately happens
I think is that the New Jerusalem is
higher than the garden that God that
this whole story this big big big story
although we don't we can't say that God
wanted the fall to happen but we can
nonetheless say that what's going to
come out of it is going to be higher
than what was there before and that the
state that we will be in at the end of
this big story is going to be higher
than the state that Adam was in at the
beginning and so this whole process of
the fall and this Redemption is also
part of making human making into
something which is closer to what God
wants closer to to revealing God in the
world so hopefully that helps a little
bit
no I don't I don't think that I don't
think that that's how the way to see it
I do I think that that everything we do
is read is is a everything that Christ
does is a form of redeeming and so we
have to we have to have the fall as part
of the story like the fall is part of
the story and then there's this this
lifting up you know I know it's not that
it's not that it's good or bad it's that
the the Christianity changes that which
was fallen into something even higher
than what was before in a pre lepsy
pre-fall environment were a man adam has
made according the image and the
likeness in a state of becoming but that
creative ass aspect existed after the
fall and that becomes corrupted it's the
same thing you mentioned Eve before
Chris's film talks about before the fall
the relationship Adam Eve is made as an
image of God that there an image it's a
nice scene in which a tearing image that
the remote coping or was persons of the
trigger co-equal the third part is
Christ that makes them an image of God
so that in Eden before the fall that
godlike impulse that creative godlike
angles existed but then becomes
corrupted and that Christ redeems that
restores that because for Chrysostom
there's the prelapsarian paradigm post
webster and on the eschatological which
restores would exist in any and you're
seeing beautiful
even higher though because of Christ but
that restores that to its rightful yes
and I think I think you're right I mean
it's clear in the story in Genesis that
that that creation that the man acts as
a small creator that is there because
that's what naming the animals is and
also the the the idea of tending the
garden that is for sure there and like
you said I think that that's the story
the story is that do we have something
before it falls
but then that fall ends up being the
vehicle by which God fills the world and
and God fills the world through even
even the scandal of the fall the whole
idea was to avoid death as much as
possible and the whole construction of
Egypt was a giant machine to sort of
keep yourself alive as much as possible
and keep your possession with you as
much as possible like the whole month of
mummification process I died and I died
my cave all my stuff with me you want to
put in a nice little jars it's going to
be alive with me in my little tomb for
all eternity but if I do it outside of
Egypt out of this thing I've created I
know I'm going to die forever and be
dead forever but when your price comes
in he doesn't avoid that embraces them
and by embracing does he actually
nullifies the effect of death that the
Egyptians were worried about which had
said that which published Egypt also
said be artistic tone for the whole
world - by doing that as well yeah so I
I would agree
I think that like I tried to explain I
think that the intuition that the
Egyptians had was was right on like it
was right on intuition because
everything we do is to avoid death right
I mean everything everything we
everything we do all human activity is
to avoid death and so I think that that
is their intuition was right and it's
still most of it is still true today but
like you said I think that Christ gives
us a new possibility and that the church
architecture and the the icon
and the tradition that the Christian
Church developed is a way to show the
alternate possibility which is this
filling up of the world with the glory
of God and so we'll talk a bit about
that later today but that's that's the
way that the church is made even the
architecture if we do go toward the
church to talk about it
that is really made to kind of connect
things together and to show us how
everything fits and everything is
directed towards this glory of God which
is which is manifesting itself in the
altar
like yeah yeah I told you it's attention
if there's a tension in Scripture and
there's a there's a constant tension
between this problem you know that if
you go too far on the outside you lose
yourself right that's just true just go
out into the woods go walk you around in
the woods you'll lose yourself if you go
too far outside of yourself but you also
need to take that if you're going to add
something to you you can't take it from
you that's the whole point of adding
something to yourself you have to take
it from the outside right your call
clothes isn't made from your body this
house isn't made from your body
all of this was taken from the outside
okay and so that's the whole problem of
the the supplement problem of the
supplement that's the whole issue and so
if you look at Scripture
you'll see I mean the Israelites didn't
come up with cherubs
there's cherubs there sphinxes Ani in
Egypt if you go to the MFA here you'll
see Babylonian cherubs you'll see these
types of there's these bull creatures
with wings and human heads and or
different types of animals with wings I
mean this is all something that was
there before the Israelites built the
tabernacle the idea of a tripartite
structure and in a temple is in every
single culture in the world so it's so
so there's nothing made up in the but
then the question is how much like how
where's that where's the line and in
Scripture there's this play you know
between the inside and the outside and
it's far more mark in the Old Testament
in the New Testament we have this idea
of Pentecost we have this idea that the
fire the holy spirit can fill up the
whole world fill up the entire cosmos
and so it changes it doesn't mean that
it's it's still there to a certain
extent but the the nature of it ends
that say the extent of it changes in air
with Christ
I haven't questioned as much as I'm
enjoying the content of what you're
saying also thinking about what you're
doing and if you have a specific work of
execution you mean in terms of Scripture
yeah I mean I have a I think everybody
should know their by well if you're a
Christian you should know your Bible I
don't care what denomination you are you
should know the Bible if you don't know
the Bible you're in your you're in
trouble because you know for for
centuries I can understand for centuries
people could surf on the common culture
and and the fact that the experts really
knew the Bible and we trusted them and
so we kind of we kind of surfed and it
was fine they was okay but we're not in
that world anymore I mean we are we are
living in the world of thorns like we
are surrounded by hostility and so we
have to know our Bible and and I think
that that's my I would say that know
your Bible that's my that's my
exhortation to the Orthodox in the room
and understand the Bible that's my
exhortation to the essentials like the
church fathers have given us amazing
amazing insight into Scripture like I
said the best reading of the Old
Testament that has ever been done that I
know of is st. Gregory of nYSSA's life
of Moses there is so much packed into
that were reads and Ephraim's hymns of
on paradise there's so much in those
texts to help you understand the threads
in Scripture these that that that
Scripture isn't just these isolated bits
of stories that don't connect but that
there are massive symbolic threads which
go all the way through Scripture and
connect to Christ and so I think that if
we're going to be Christians today we
really need that
because not we're going to we won't know
what to answer to the to the world
because the world is bashing at our door
with a massive hammer so we have to be
able to answer that it also sort of
God's call and Adams Lanza kind of like
sort of harmony and I see sort of in
this pattern like crisis as the second
atom using certain special that you said
stretches that is partly to like Oliver
Asian kind of like going about that
garden and bring all things into
heartbeat the task that was initially
counselor wears out
so can maybe this is more like the
illogical like what is me so the the
idea that Christ was the lamb slain
before the foundation of the world comes
in tonight so Christ's like deep this
stuff before
chaotically ever ensued how much would
this is kind of just like a mental
constructs
I so if if crisis Arnie why don't we
write well because we're free that's one
part the way that I the way that I kind
of understand it is is you can see it at
these as these loops these loops that
are getting bigger something like that
where Christ plants the seed and in
crisis like the seed for the kingdom of
God and the kingdom of God is gathering
all of us also into that kingdom so it
has to have a cosmic there has to be a
cosmic version of what Christ did and
we're playing that out right we have to
participate in that in our own in our
freedom and so some people totally
experience that completely absolutely we
call them Saints they they completely
enter our deified enter into the life of
God become one with God you know our
become pure glory we read the stories of
people not that long ago who seemed to
have gone gone through that and so we
can but but we have to it has to be real
like we actually have to participate we
have to participate in this process for
it to happen
Farage was about which is participate
we have a choice to participate in
the continual yeah yeah we need to you
have to understand that's one of the
things that one of the one of the
diseases of the modern age and and
modern biblical understanding is that
we've made put the Bible out there and
now we are here and we are interpreting
this thing that's out there and and it's
something that's outside of us and so
it's like a scientific and it's like a
phenomena that we have to analyze but
that's not right that's not Christianity
we are in the same story that Bible at
the end of that Bible that story keeps
going we're part of the same story
that's there that's our story we're in
that story it's not something outside of
us
it's far
it was developed to dwell in the
Shekinah the presence of God that idea
of communion with God and the Christian
liturgical space that same that same
idea of Kino neo Communion when we
looked when to speak to the 24th I mean
even in the West the Mystics the early
Christmas Catholic you know Western
mystics experienced that kind of
ecstatic experience right after
communion so how does that the
liturgical space as as heaven on earth
that type of idea that idea of coming
into the presence of God now for for the
Israelites it was in hamako it was one
place they had to be on the Temple Mount
in that specific place where in the Holy
of Holies is where Abraham went to
sacrifice Isaac Isaac how does that
relate into the Christian the church
but in the hole or just probably
stuffing that part no no yeah yeah but
it's okay no we searched the church
structure is based on the old test but
it's not completely there's a there's
some flips in there that are interesting
and so one of the things that like
father was saying the Old Testament
there was the temple and then if you
wanted to experience the presence of God
you had to actually go into the temple
but you never really could experience
the presence of God because only only
the Holy only the priests only the high
priest could actually enter into the the
Holy of Holies and so in the Christian
tradition what we've done is without
confusion because this is one of the
problems that we actually see in the
modern world today is that without
confusion without without annulling the
distinction between us and God without
annulling the distinction between that
which is profane that which is holy
we've created a way to participate all
of us in that process and so it's not
that we destroy hierarchy which is
something that certainly modern
Christians think is the result of Christ
not that we destroy hierarchy is that
the hierarchy is this per Mia's thing of
love coming from above and of us
participating from below all of this is
this is there's this organic
relationship happening and one of the
things that Christ does is he joins
opposites together like I hope that
you've seen it just in this image that's
what Christ does one of the crazy things
about the Christian churches would
people I don't know why people don't
talk about this the Old Testament in the
Old Testament the temple and the
tabernacle was flipped from us it was it
was the other way around which is that
the Holy of Holies was in the West and
the entrance of the tabernacle was in
the east so you can understand it as the
presence of God rising up in the east
and landing onto the onto the altar
hello unto the yes the Holy of Holies
the the the the Ark of the Covenant
that's what I was looking for sorry
so rising oven eats and landing onto the
Ark of the Covenant and the altar was on
the out was in the outer Court so there
was this there was this flip between the
Ark which was inside the Holy of Holies
and the altar which was on the outside
where the sacrifice occurred okay so
there's relationship to the outside and
the inside the sacrifice the glory from
east to west now in the Christian
tradition the very first churches that
we have are actually in that direction
the first church is in Rome all have the
holy place in the West but soon very
soon it it flipped where the holy place
got put in the East but what's in our
holy place we have an altar and the Holy
of Holies
that wasn't the tabernacle the
tabernacle the altar was outside and the
Ark of the Covenant was inside and we
have actually joined the inside and the
outside together we've taken the altar
we've brought it into the Holy of Holies
but it's still the Ark of the Covenant
as well so on the altar you find the
menorah you know you often you'll have a
menorah on the altar
you'll have certain tropes that are
there to refer you to remember that this
is also the Ark of the Covenant and that
if you understand what Christ does
that's what Christ does all the time he
joins the opposites together into one
and so what we've done is we still have
a hierarchy but we so we still have a
veil we still have a separation between
the Holy of Holies and
the knave but that veil will open and
the holy thing will come out into the
world and we will participate completely
in that holy thing right that none of
that was in the old tech none of that
was in the temple there was none of that
we are actually participating in the
holiest thing when we engage in the
Liturgy is that does that make sense
there's a lot of stuff we could talk
about there's so much to talk about in
terms of the difference and the
relationship between the Christian
temple and the Jewish temple it's other
Christ to nature's the divine
join indivisibly and confused exactly
and that's the the key to Christianity
is to understand unity without confusion
that's that's if you want to understand
everything about Christianity it's unity
without confusion if you want to
understand what love is love is unity
without confusion that's what love is
because when you when you love someone
you are completely united with them but
you don't fuse into them right you don't
you don't swallow someone you know you
don't drink you don't completely annul
their individuality when you love them
know you respect their separateness from
you but you are in complete communion
and that's that the image of the Trinity
is exactly that three distinct
completely absolutely distinct persons
without confusion but completely one
without division it seems like an aporia
but it's the key to understanding how
reality works actually it's the key to
understanding how everything exists and
so yeah that in Christianity that's what
that's that's what it does and as we
watch Christianity break apart we see
the confusion set in then we see
elements of Christianity which are then
taken on their own you know the word
heresy that the word heresy means that
like a choice means to choose something
that seems to me but most heresies are
which is that you take one aspect and
then you just take that one aspect and
you don't you don't keep it so it's true
but it's not true alone it's true when
it's related to everything else and so
there is an aspect for example that that
we participate in the glory of God and
that we have access to the glory of God
and that the glory of God comes down to
us but in the Christian tradition
there's never been this idea that
there's no hierarchy at all just not
there it's a modern idea that there's
absolutely no hierarchy that we're all
the same that's not true and yeah and
and so it's the same with there's
there's so many things like that where
we've taken one aspect out of out of
Christianity want to make it only about
that want to make Christ just the really
nice guy
who helps and loves people and takes
care of the widow and the orphan and he
does that he definitely does that right
but he's also the one with the whip who
goes in and you know and whips the
moneychangers and he's also the one who
was constantly rebuking his disciples
and telling them that they don't
understand anything
so it's Christ is everything you're
boiled into one all right I think I
think I think we've got